[Music]
we've been doing something on the show
lately that was actually inspired by
Puppy Bowl on Animal Planet
yeah there's Puppy Bowl that they shut
down the Super Bowl and this inspired us
and we started doing it to become very
popular so lens develops go to it now
tonight's installment of Puppy Conan
[Applause]
there's puppy common puppy Kannan is
inspecting yes pump behaving baby
and II puppy conan inspecting the set
just as I do help them out they're handy
and he often does the same thing during
a show yeah there you go oh you saved
him that's nice
I got off I gotta take my wig off yeah
take his wig off then take your wig off
Andy tonight is a special treat we also
have added puppy lebombo let's see puppy
lebombo that isn't gonna many popular
[Applause]
- what
why is his mustache on top of his nose
okay I'm out there Andy
he's good and of course the special
guests on tonight's puppy Conan puppy
Lady gaga welcome
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
so free tonight and why a mustache on
top of his nose that makes no sense
because he'd probably eat it otherwise
just like the real Obama okay
[Applause]
I promise you ladies and gentlemen we
are going to do a full hour of Conan on
this set that is
I love it here but but with 12 more
puppies puppies
I just love the idea of anyone tuning in
right now the anti-growth ray really
worked go Oh puppy the Bombo
alright let's definitely have in a
minute no puppy la Bamba I'll kiss you
later ladies and gentlemen